i believe loving your work is a right
and not a privilege i despise the fact
i lament the fact i curse the fact that
so few people get to say
i love my job as if they've won some
lottery you know you go out with your
friends and somebody says i love my job
and everybody goes oh my god you're so
lucky right
that to me is madness everybody
the vast majority should get to wake up
and say i love my job it is a right
it is a god-given right that we should
love where we work
and we should demand it we should demand
that our leaders provide an environment
in which we want to come where we want
to care about each other
where we feel safe to express our
vulnerabilities and our fears and our
concerns that we're open
to correction and discipline and
feedback that we're not defensive
because we know that it's being given to
help us improve and grow and we want to
improve and grow
and in turn we will help others improve
and grow because when we feel safe
when we feel that our leaders
care more about us than a number
they care more about our lives
and our confidence and our joy and our
skill set more than some short-term gain
that they care more about our priorities
than the priorities of some
disinterested external constituency then
we will respond in kind and we will
offer our blood and our sweat and our
tears and we will make sacrifices of all
kinds
to see that our leader's vision is
advanced and that this company continues
to thrive
not for them for ourselves it becomes
deeply personal
it becomes something we love
contributing to i talk about it all the
time
working hard for something we don't care
about is called stress
working hard for something we love is
called passion
and i'm tired of listening to ceo saying
we only hire passionate people
what you don't even know what that means
how do you know that they're passionate
for interviewing and not passionate for
working
you know every person on the planet has
passion
right we just don't all have passion for
the same things give me something to
believe in
give me something to believe and give me
the opportunity to contribute to
something
allow me to make mistakes and try again
and you'll have passion up the wazoo